[Music]
my mom is so sophisticated i was born
wearing a bow tie my mama's so
magnificent when she farts
it's followed by a
rainbow my mom is so sweet she can't
stand in the rain because she'll melt
because she's made a sugar mother
my mama is so
patient
my mama is so generous that she tried to
give me up for adoption 32 times
hello
my mama is so anti-racist that she had a
somewhat black baby
my mama is so
patient
she carried me
where are you
i got a joke it's a mama joke my mom is
so sweet when she touches a muffin it
turns into a cupcake my mom is so
nurturing she breast fed me until the
age of seven
can we not use that i would love to not
my mama got it
rolling
my mama is so patient
when she
wakes up
man should we
keep i got it i got it i gotta go just
stay on me okay my mama is so french
sometimes people are like what
my mom was so generous last hanukkah she
gave me two hundred dollars we're not
even jewish
it's at 8 pm man i don't care then don't
ask me to do this
okay you know
they didn't make godfather three in one
hour my mama is so magnificent she
taught me how to do this
thanks mom
happy mother's day everybody to all the
moms out there
my mama your mama
all right thank you good good glad we
got it